[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
michaël delafosse bonjour michaël
delafosse mer rouge où beaucoup d'être
avec nous vous êtes le nouveau maire
socialiste de montpellier on est
ensemble pendant un bon quart d'heure
pour une interview en partenariat avec
la presse quotidienne régionale
représenté par fabrice veysseyre aux
dons du groupe mais bravo jean fabbri
son genre yann bonjour monsieur michael
delafosse vous semble donc victorieux
d'une campagne qu'on a qualifié de
campagne la plus folle de france est ce
que pour vous devenir maire de
montpellier
ça représente un rêve une mission un
aboutissement une responsabilité lourde
vu l'ampleur du travail qui nous attend
c'est j'emploie cette expression plutôt
c'est les montpelliérains qui nous l'ont
dit c'est les douze travaux d'hercule
notre ville montpellier a eu un maire
très emblématique georges frêche qui a
marqué sa période de maire bâtisseur et
qu'il me soit permis de lui rendre
hommage
mais aujourd'hui on ouvre un nouveau
chapitre de la ville où la ville doit
être au rendez vous des défis du siècle
les enjeux climatiques
les enjeux dans la crise qui s'annonce
très difficile où il faut relocaliser
une partie de nos activités donc les
territoires vont jouer là un rôle très
important et par exemple sur les enjeux
de santé notre ville peut se positionner
de manière encore plus forte que ce
qu'elle ne le fut de par le passé et
puis les enjeux de cohésion sociale je
pense là aux enjeux éducatifs je pense
là à la politique de la ville dans les
quartiers et donc une nouvelle approche
du développement urbain montpellier a de
ce point de vue marquer un dessin qui
était le développement vers la mer il
est nécessaire aujourd'hui d'affirmer un
rééquilibrage de la ville et puis le
défi immense des mobilités des mobilité
décarbonée pour répondre à l'enjeu
climatique
nous avons fait dans cette campagne que
vous avez qualifié de fun
des propositions extrêmement sérieuse et
responsable autour des mobilités
alternatives à la voiture justement
gratuité des transports pour les
habitants de la métropole place du vélo
ce point de vue là ma homologues de
strasbourg va faire beaucoup mais je
sais qu'elle a déjà beaucoup d' avance
dans sa danse sur son territoire et moi
j'entends bien la rattraper michaël
delafosse ont évoqué cette cette
campagne un peu folle au coeur de
laquelle vous vous êtes retrouvé
on rappelle que au début de la campagne
dans les sondages vous étiez crédité de
6% d'intentions de vote
qu'est ce qui fait qu'on gagne une
campagne d'élection partant d'aussi loin
et puis ma deuxième question qui va avec
la première est ce que quelque part et
vous évoquer le cas de strasbourg à
l'instant vous ne devez pas votre
élection aux écologistes à montpellier
écoutez nous avons été moins les
sondages ces sondages 6% et nous avons
obtenu 48 % au 2e tour alors que le saut
le meilleur sondage nous donnait à 40
alors qu'est ce qui fait qu'on remporte
ce succès je vais le dire manière très
posé de mon point de vue d'abord vous
avez évoqué dans votre présentation que
j'étais socialiste et ce dont je suis
fier je crois que la constance a des
idées à des valeurs dans un contexte où
beaucoup de gens changent de camp
fonction de leurs intérêts électoraux et
bien ça c'est un gage de confiance
ensuite dans ce que vous avez qualifié
la presse nationale la folle campagne de
montpellier se comportait de manière
sérieuse
en parlant de ses valeurs de ses idées
de son projet en se tenant à grande
distance de la critique de la polémique
de l'outrance qui caractérise parfois le
débat politique mais en étant sur les
projets en invitant les habitants de
notre ville à construire un destin
commun en leur parlant de la sécurité de
la laïcité des enjeux de mobilité en
parlant à leur intelligence et bien vous
recréer un lien
confiance qui fait que progressivement
vous vous entraînez une dynamique et
puis je suis sur public sénat et les
sénateurs et sénatrices connaissent cela
sa savante passe de devenir mère moi je
suis engagé dans ma ville depuis
toujours sous la forme associative avec
un engagement politique est une ville
sas arpente ça se sillonnent on sent
m'imprègne et à un moment quand dans
notre élection en tout cas ce qu'a fait
notre succès bien sûr les hommes et
femmes de gauche et de l'écologie se
sont reconnus dans notre démarche de
deux questions politiques michael de la
face après on va revenir sur vos
propositions pour montpellier mais deux
questions politiques puisque vous en
parlez vous êtes militant socialiste
depuis votre adolescence on a beaucoup
parlé de sexe de cette vague verte
est ce que ça vous a agacé et est ce que
vous dites ou vous craignez
qu'aujourd'hui les verts sont en train
d'écraser les socialistes mais mais mais
mais arrêtez arrêtez ça c'est la
caricature
moi je suis socialiste et écologiste où
je suis socialiste donc écologistes les
socialistes dans l'histoire de france
ils ont su être la modernité et
aujourd'hui sur les questions
écologiques comme jeune père de famille
qui voit et qui pensent à l'avenir de
ses enfants comme professeur d'histoire
géographie qui voient mes élèves de 4e
séché les cours parce qu'il marche pour
le climat - en tant que socialiste je
dois faire que notre pensée soit au
rendez-vous des défis qui se posent et
quand j'ai lancé notre campagne en
défendant la gratuité des transports
j'ai voulu répondre à cette aspiration
de la jeunesse qui marche pour le climat
d'avoir un maire qui agit pour le climat
et commandes de gauche
habité par les idéaux justice sociale
est bien la gratuité des transports mais
l'addition de jouer ton parti tu es ce
que c'est toujours compatit michael de
la face et pas moi qui le dit c'est
olivier faure le premier secrétaire du
parti socialiste qui disait mardi
ça va frotter sur certains sujets avec
les écologistes mais olivier faure il
est chef du parti socialiste moi je suis
maire de montpellier et mes ambitions en
matière d'écologie de transition
écologique sont connus et ce sont des
engagements pris devant les
montpellierains d'autres socialistes
dans d'autres territoires ont défendu
d'autres engagements avec la sensibilité
de leur territoire moi je le dis si les
socialistes au 21ème siècle ne sont pas
au rendez-vous ou maintenant l'écologie
au coeur de leurs paradigmes mais ils
seront balayés la gravité la grille est
aussi un sport michael fort vous allez
la mettre en pratique dans votre dans
votre ville et votre agglomération
enfin monsieur excusez-moi j'ai pris cet
engagement devant les électeurs c'est le
premier il sera honoré je vais pas
commencer à être à peine élu maire est à
dire que je ne vais pas tenir un
engagement fin i
on est attendu hier j'ai démissionné de
mon poste de conseiller départemental
conformément à mes engagements sur le
cumul des mandats je veux je vous le dis
que je vaux se trouve votre question
surprenante
ça veut dire que ça veut dire que les
engagements que vous avez pris pendant
la campagne vont être appliqués à mais
je vais je vais mettre en oeuvre les
engagements forts d'une légitimité et je
le dis très sereinement
ils seront honorés et si nous
rencontrons à un moment donné à neuf ce
tacle parce qu'on ne peut pas tenir tel
engagement
mais on se retournera vers la population
et on expliquera pourquoi ce qu' il ya
eu un problème de faisabilité un
obstacle et on va continuer à parler à
l'intelligence des citoyens
michaël delafosse se défausser on va
revenir sur votre programme et sur
l'actualité vous parlez beaucoup de
santé dans votre programme vous parlait
même de souveraineté sanitaire de
montpellier d'elle ségur de la santé qui
s'achève aujourd'hui qu'est ce que vous
en attendez pour les montpelliérains et
pour le pays
moi j'en attends beaucoup pour les
personnels hospitaliers du service
public hospitalier
ont besoin du soutien et que on a bien
vu qu'il ya une inversion des valeurs
enfin on peut pas parler l'argent
récompensé dignement les traders et
mépriser ceux qui ont incarné ce que la
société a eu le meilleur durant cette
crise je le dis fortement donc j'espère
une revalorisation des personnels un
soutien aux en termes d'investissements
pour l'hôpital public à montpellier les
enjeux sont très importants et avec les
parlementaires les sénateurs et les
députés nous prendrons un rendez vous
avec monsieur vivant pour qu'il
accompagne l'hôpital de montpellier
mais je vais vous dire je crois à la
décentralisation ce qu'a fait françois
mitterrand est une opportunité
exceptionnelle pour créer une société de
responsabilité et demain en tant que
maire nous allons travailler sur les
problématiques d'accès aux soins ou
aussi paradoxal que ce soit à
montpellier
il existe des déserts médicaux dans des
quartiers populaires qui engorgent les
urgences et qui rendent difficile
l'exercice des urgentistes dans leur
mission est donc dans les quartiers où
il ya des déserts médicaux ou des
familles parce que leurs enfants à 40 de
fièvre ne trouve pas de professionnels
de santé en partenariat avec la rs dans
le cadre d'un contrat local de santé qui
sera signé nous allons être nous allons
être dans l'esprit de la
décentralisation et prend des
initiatives pour répondre à ces
problèmes et très modestement parce que
j'observe que d'autres maires d'ailleurs
ou engager des choses très novatrice là
dessus et donc sur la santé accès aux
soins protection sociale à travers la
mutuelle communal mais aussi enjeux du
développement économique à travers
l'écosystème de la santé de
l'alimentation l'environnement développé
au nord de montpellier une maître valet
le 17 août nous cite nous nous fêtons
les 800 ans de la faculté de médecine de
montpellier car un patrimoine
exceptionnel mais qui est surtout
extrêmement tourné vers la vie
et ma responsabilité en tant que futur
présent la métropole c'est d'accompagner
ce ce développement du point de vue du
développement économique pour notre
territoire
vous parlez beaucoup de décentralisation
michaël delafosse le chef de l'état dans
son interview à la presse quotidienne
régionale dit qu'il faut retrouver le
dialogue entre les élus et tous les
territoires il appelle à une nouvelle
conférence des territoires est-ce que
vous êtes prêts à participer ou est ce
que vous dites
l'heure n'est plus aux conférences
l'heure est aux actes écoutez moi je
suis toujours pour le dialogue
quand il ya des espaces de dialogue
c'est important parce que ça évite la
violence dans notre société
et si le mais le chef de l'état doit
entendre un message est est ce qu a dit
monsieur qui rouge tout à l'heure je le
partage totalement totalement lors de la
crise des gilets jaunes
les partenaires sociaux n'ont pas été
sollicités résultat ça finit en violence
et après le chef de l'état a pris des
engagements il a réuni dans le cadre du
grand débat les élus locaux
il est temps de passer à l'acte s'il ya
une conférence je viendrai avec des
propositions et je suis sûr que tous les
nouveaux maires élus seront très
proactifs en termes de propositions
qu'elle doit être la priorité soit go
qu'il soit clair qu'ils ne touchent pas
au calendrier électoral des
départementales et des régionales il
faut être sérieux faut être sérieux
les rendez vous démocratique doivent
être lisibles on va les mettre après la
présidentielle et transformer notre
république en république plébiscitaire
alors qu'au contraire il faut avoir des
des confrontations démocratique pour
savoir sur quel dossier le territoire
prennent telle ou telle orientation
alors moi je le dis il faut soutenir les
collectivités locales et on en a besoin
du point de vue de l'investissement pour
la relance économique pour nous nos
choix d'investissement l'esprit ce sera
le green new deal et donc nous voulons
accompagner le chef de l'état dans les
objectifs de la cap 21
et pour ça il faut pas qu'on soit dans
un dialogue de comptable mais dans un
dialogue de confiance pour que les
territoires sera à lille
initiative et a pleinement dynamique sur
les enjeux de la transition écologique
de la reprise en termes d'emplois sur
l'innovation et on l'a bien vu dans la
crise sanitaire les territoires ils ont
joué un rôle incroyable et donc il faut
envoyer des messages de de confiance ce
n'est pas un message de défiance contre
l'état dont notre pays a besoin parce
qu'il est garant des principes
républicains
mais on a besoin de territoire où tous
les hommes et femmes qui s'engagent
puisse exercer au plus près la
responsabilité pour agir juste et de
manière plus efficace
emmanuel macron que dont vous avez dû
lire interview j'imagine ce matin dans
les colonnes de la presse quotidienne
régionale annonce une entrée difficile
après la crise sanitaire ou pendant avec
les sanitaires qui n'est pas totalement
terminée une rentrée une rentrée sociale
économique difficile
vous préparez comment montpellier à tout
cela d'abord il faut être très conscient
de la situation pour matin partager le
constat des mesures macro ou partager le
constater je le constate emmanuel macron
l'entend tous les jours quand on
rencontre les chefs d'entreprise et
surtout les familles des jeunes qui
s'apprêtent à entrer sur le marché du
travail et qui ont une boule au ventre
pour leurs enfants
tant la situation semble très difficile
et donc là il faut une la mobilisation
de tous à toutes les échelles en tout
cas pour ce qui me concerne dès que je
deviendrai le président de la métropole
nous allons constituer nous en avions
parlé chère madame lors du débat une
texte force avec l'ensemble des acteurs
économiques pour que filière par filière
nous nous fassions état des lieux
saulieu solution des possibles pour
accompagner tous les secteurs dans cette
crise et je le dis dans ce contexte il
faut que nous fassions bloc et c'est pas
le moment de s'égarer dans les débats
sur le calendrier électoral mais que
l'ensemble des collectivités
territoriales reçoivent du chef de
l'état un message de confiance et je
sais qu'il a qu'il en est conscient j'en
suis convaincu et que nous puissions est
au plus près des consulaire
des partenaires sociaux pour accompagner
les entreprises et les aider à tirer de
cette crise par dont une opportunité
pour accompagner un changement modèle en
faveur la transition écologique donc la
gravité nous on y est on va y être
confrontés tous les jours en se vendant
nos permanences d'élus des gens qui ont
perdu qui vont perdre leur emploi des
entrepreneurs qui sont en situation
d'extrême inquiétude les salles de
concerts qui risquent de fermer et donc
des lieux de culture tous les toute
l'économie de l'événementiel à travers
l'activité de congrès est en grande
difficulté pour ça que par exemple nous
nous allons créer un fonds de garantie
pour aider à programmer l'activité et si
jamais on reconsidère par malheur eh
bien on puisse prendre en charge les
risques mais il faut que les assureurs
soient partie prenante de ce type de
fonds axa que tout le monde fait ce
cross de responsabilité et merci
beaucoup michael de la face on aura
l'occasion bien sûr de vous recevoir à
nouveau dans cette émission merci
d'avoir été notre premier invité
politique ce matin dans quelques
instants va recevoir jeanne marseillan
la maire écologiste de strasbourg vous
avez peut-être un petit mot pour elle
elle vous entends de d'abord dû adresser
des félicitations pour sa très belle
élection elle a déjoué les pronostics et
je je je suis sûr qu'on pourra
travailler ensemble parce que à
montpellier strasbourg paris toutes nos
métropoles doivent rejoindre les villes
du monde dans la dans l'action face à
l'urgence climatique à la fois pour être
résilient est pleinement mobilisée j'ai
hâte
très vite chers jeunes de te rencontrer
pour voir où nous pouvons coopérer
ensemble
en tout cas félicitations et merci à
public sénat de nous avoir donné en tout
cas de m'avoir donné la parole ce matin
merci à vous merci michael delafosse
d'avoir été avec nous peut-être une
réponse rapide jeanne d'arc c'est gyan
avant de vous entendre sur le reste
amicale de la fosse oui merci merci
beaucoup pour
messages de félicitations qui me va
droit au coeur est très très heureuse à
l'idée de pouvoir coopérer avec
l'ensemble des grandes villes françaises
dans des des réseaux de téléphone et
merci beaucoup merci michael delafosse
d'avoir été avec nous depuis montpellier